[Música]
más de 200 personas detenidas dejó un
allanamiento de la policía en el campus
de la universidad San Marcos en Lima los
uniformados buscaban desalojar a cientos
de manifestantes la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos pidió
al Estado peruano rendir cuentas sobre
lo sucedido
apartan del cargo al jefe del ejército
de Brasil el presidente Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva tomó la decisión en el
marco de las tensiones generadas tras la
toma de edificios de los poderes
públicos por parte de manifestantes
bolsonaristas
el gobierno colombiano y la guerrilla
del eln retomarán el diálogo el próximo
13 de febrero ambas partes se reunieron
este sábado en Caracas para superar la
crisis generada tras la declaración
unilateral de un ces el fuego declarado
por el gobierno de Gustavo Petro
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Perú la policía protagonizó impactantes
imágenes después de entrar en la
Universidad Nacional mayor de San Marcos
derribando el portón principal un
operativo que dejó más de 200 detenidos
algunos con cargos de terrorismo la
universidad estaba haciendo usada como
bastión de las protestas estudiantiles y
como un albergue para los manifestantes
que llegaron del resto del país para
protestar contra el gobierno de Tina
boluarte tiene más detalles
es la universidad más antigua de América
con cerca de 500 años de historia la
policía peruana derribó con una tanqueta
a la puerta de la Universidad Nacional
mayor de San Marcos de Lima después
detuvo a más de 200 personas algunas
acusadas de cargos de terrorismo
[Aplausos]
sangre
por qué nos están matando la convención
americana sobre Derechos Humanos en su
principio sexto habla de inviolabilidad
del espacio académico la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos pidió
al Estado peruano rendir cuentas y
criticó la detención masiva de personas
cdh expresa su preocupación por la
incursión policial del desalojo y
detenciones masivas en la universidad de
San Marcos exhorta Con urgencia al
Estado a rendir cuentas sobre los hechos
y garantizar la integridad y debido
proceso de todas las personas la
universidad de San Marcos fue utilizada
por los estudiantes como albergue para
peruanos llegados desde todo el país
para protestar contra el gobierno de
Dina boluarte la rectoría había
denunciado el viernes la expulsión del
personal de seguridad y el robo de sus
elementos por parte de manifestantes el
Ministerio Público señaló que fue la
universidad quien solicitó la
intervención
[Música]
la Universidad Nacional mayor de San
Marcos fue fundada el 12 de mayo de 1551
es un centro público conocido por ser un
bastión histórico para la izquierda y un
epicentro de protesta y reivindicación
en Brasil el presidente Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva despidió al jefe del
ejército el general Julio César arrudá
quien había asumido el cargo el pasado
28 de diciembre y en su reemplazo estará
Tomás Miguel Ribeiro paiva comandante
del ejército del sureste el cambio se
marca en el ambiente de tensión que dejó
el asalto del pasado 8 de enero a los
edificios de los poderes públicos en
Brasilia Lula da Silva había dicho que
sospechaba una colusión del personal de
las fuerzas armadas en la insurrección
de otro lado la Corte Suprema ordenó que
de los 1.406 detenidos por los hechos
942 entrarán en prisión preventiva
mientras los otros disfrutarán de la
libertad provisional
la Corte Suprema de Brasil ordenó la
prisión preventiva a 942 de los 1406
detenidos por los actos del 8 de enero
en Brasilia según el magistrado
Alexander de moraes instructor del caso
se quedarán en prisión preventiva por
participar en terrorismo y destrucción
de bienes públicos y son acusados de
asociación criminal abolición violenta
del Estado de derecho y golpe de estado
las otras 464 personas serán liberadas
provisionalmente y estarán bajo medidas
cautelares esta semana el presidente
Lula se reunió por primera vez con el
ejército para investigar una posible
implicación de las fuerzas armadas en la
insurrección sin embargo el ministro de
defensa del país afirmó que no tuvieron
un papel directo en los disturbios
tengo entendido que las fuerzas armadas
no estuvieron directamente involucradas
ahora bien si algún elemento individual
tuvo su participación responderá como
Ciudadano
no tengo la menor duda de que otro de
estos hechos no ocurrirá porque las
fuerzas armadas lo anticiparán
el pasado 8 de enero miles de
partidarios de Jair por sonoro
invadieron y la sede del Congreso de la
Corte Suprema y del palacio presidencial
en la capital Brasilia pedían una
intervención militar para derrocar al
presidente Lula que resultó elegido por
un estrecho margen en octubre pasado
sobre bolsonaro seguimos en Brasil
porque este sábado se celebró el Día
Mundial de la religión que coincide en
esta nación con la jornada del combate a
la intolerancia religiosa en este país
solo en el primer semestre de 2022
fueron contabilizadas 545 quejas de
intolerancia la mayoría en las ciudades
de Sao Paulo y Río de Janeiro es un dato
que revela Un aumento del
45,6%, veamos el informe de nuestra
corresponsal Valeria sakone
[Música]
Hoy es Día de rezo en este templo
dedicado al candomblé es una religión
que llegó a Brasil de la mano de los más
de cinco millones de esclavos africanos
estamos en la mallada fluminense en la
periferia de Río de Janeiro donde el
miedo tras una ola de ataques violentos
contra terrenos como llaman a esos
templos los autores son narcotraficantes
convertidos a la religión evangélica
son personas que dicen no quiero que el
[__] viva más aquí ahora quien vive
aquí es Dios nosotros seríamos el
demonio
esta religiosa da voz a quienes están
amenazados de muerte a pesar de su
perfil militante reconoce que tiene
miedo
mis amigos me dicen hermana sal de aquí
esto es peligroso no sigas denunciando
los ataques Déjalo para este estudioso
detrás de la intolerancia religiosa está
el racismo estructural
Este es un proyecto de estado es un
proyecto político hegemónico que quiere
que los cristianos sean hegemónicos que
sean la comunidad que pueda gozar de
todos sus derechos mientras que las
otras religiones como el espiritismo la
onda y el están fuera de ese proyecto
pero un sector de los evangélicos se
opone a tanta violencia
klever es una estrella de la música
gospell cantó la investidura del
presidente Lula su apoyo explícito a las
religiones de matriz africana le ha
costado varios ataques por partes de sus
fans antes de ser cristianos soy un
hombre negro que creció en una Favela yo
fui criado en un ambiente muy plural
desde el momento en que veo en la
sociedad siendo una figura pública
templos atacados Víctimas de la
intolerancia religiosa no puedo quedarme
callado
es el ejemplo vivo de que no todos los
evangélicos son intolerantes ni se
identifican con el fundamentalismo
religioso
en Venezuela fue excarcelado el
exministro de interior y Justicia Miguel
Rodríguez Torres quien había permanecido
cinco años en prisión acusado de
instigar a la rebelión después de
distanciarse del chavismo en 2014 el
exministro dirigió la respuesta policial
del gobierno a la oleada de protestas
gubernamentales que se saldó con 43
personas muertas y cientos de heridos
hechos por los que líderes de la
oposición exigen que rinda cuentas
después de su excarcelación Rodríguez
partió rumbo a España
el gobierno de Colombia y el ejército de
liberación nacional retomarán el diálogo
el próximo 13 de febrero en México y
allí discutirán la posibilidad de un
cese el fuego bilateral así lo dieron a
conocer durante una declaración conjunta
tras una reunión entre ambas partes este
sábado en Caracas el encuentro estaba
destinado a superar la crisis provocada
en diciembre cuando el gobierno de
Gustavo Petro anunció un cese el fuego
que fue desmentido por el grupo armado
para que funcione hay que acordar reglas
del juego que se llaman protocolos y a
su vez esos protocolos cubren a las
fuerzas armadas del estado y porque
obligan a ambos Entonces eso va a
demandar Pues un tiempo pero esperamos
de que como se va a trabajar varias
semanas en México lograr avanzar
sustancialmente en noticias de Estados
Unidos el departamento de Justicia
encontró un nuevo paquete de documentos
clasificados en la casa del presidente
Joe biden en Delaware así lo comunicó el
abogado del mandatario Bob quien dijo
que en total se hallaron seis documentos
durante una requisa que duró unas Trece
horas Bauer agregó que el departamento
de Justicia también se llevó Unas notas
de vaiden escritas a mano que datan de
su periodo como vicepresidente durante
la era Obama
hasta que este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con nosotros
[Música]